تعتبر
المملكة العربية السعودية هذا نطاقًا سعريًا قويًا ولكن ليس طموحًا بشكل مفرط
إذا تم تسليمه ، فقد يمنح أرامكو السعودية
المرتبة الأولى في
فئتين رئيسيتين الشركة الأكثر
قيمة وأكبر طرح عام أولي
مع النطاق السعري من ثمانية دولارات إلى
ثمانية دولارات و  53 سنتًا لتقاسم
القيمة الإجمالية لعملاق النفط سيكون
واحدًا وستة إلى واحد فاصل سبعة
وتريليون دولار تفوق شركة أبل بما
لا يقل عن أربعمائة مليون دولار إذا
حققت نطاقًا أعلى ، فإن البيع
سيجمع أكثر من خمسة وعشرين مليار دولار
مما يجعله أكبر.  من ظهور علي بابا لأول
مرة في عام 2014
ضمن مجموعته النظيرة حول Co
سيكون أيضًا خمسة أضعاف
القيمة السوقية لشركات الطاقة الأمريكية
Exxon Mobil أو Chevron لكن أرامكو
تحارب تيارًا قويًا
يسحب المستثمرين بعيدًا عن النفط الكبير مع
مخاوف بشأن تغير المناخ و
إمكانات ما يسمى ذروة النفط
حيث لم تنخفض مستويات الطلب عن
ولي العهد الطموح في المملكة
محمد بن سلمان ، الذي عقد
العزم على طرح هذا الاكتتاب العام في السوق
بعد عدة تأخيرات في وقت ما
، طرح الرجل المعروف باسم MBS فكرة
إدراج بنسبة 5٪ في
نيويورك ولندن أو في آسيا كجزء من
خطته الرئيسية لفطم المملكة العربية السعودية.
لقد تم تقليص هذه التطلعات النبيلة
إلى الحجم مع هدف
واحد ونصف في المائة من ثلث ذلك
المخصص لمستثمري التجزئة السعوديين ،
ومع ذلك فهو معلم مهم
وربما محاولة للمضي قدمًا
بعد مقتل الصحفي السعودي جمال
خاشقجي في عام 2018.  واعتقالات
المليارديرات السعوديين في فندق ريتز
كارلتون في العام السابق لهذين الحادثين يقوضان
الثقة
وقد لا تكون شركات النفط الاستثمارية الأجنبية في الموضة ولكن لا
أحد يستطيع أن يجادل في سجل أرامكو
باعتبارها الشركة الأكثر ربحية في العالم ،
جون تيفت أرياس CNN business London
[  موسيقى]